ان نضال شعبنا من اجل بناء دوله المؤسسات
ودوله ديموقراطيه ما زال متواصلا انه صار
فيه اجهاض الثوره متعارف انه وجدت هذه
الثوره بالاساس بقرار اقليمي وقرار دولي
وضعف الطبقه السياسيه التي انهارت امام
يعني هي التهديدات صارت عمليه يعني ضرب
الثوره والثوره المضاده التي اخذت زمامه
الامور منذ
2014 فشلت تماما في اداره المرحله وهي
الان اخر مراحل فشلها بح حيث ما ما نشاهده
اليوم اقتصادي واجتماع عيد منظومه الثوره
المضاده وظهور الشارع الان من جديد بقوه
ومطالبته برحيل المغتربي الاخير يدل على
ان الثوره ما زالت متواصله والامل ما زال
موجود وانا دائما اريد ان ابعث الثقه وروح
الامل في في شعب
كل المؤامرات على ورامج والمصار مازلنا
قائلين ومازلنا واقفين وانا عندي قناعه ان
الثوره ستتجدد مسارها يعني مسار تاريخي
طويل المدى قبل ان تتغير يعني هكذا 16
سنوات هي تحتاج الى كثير من الوقت الى
كثير من التجارب الى احيانا يعني توقف
تراجع لكن هذا هو المسار الطبيعي وانا
فخور بشعبنا اليوم لانه اظهر انه فعلا
ثوره ما زالت حيا ما زالت موجوده في
القلوب والان الان مسؤوليه كل الاطراف
انها تمر الى ما بعد هذا اليوم لان هذا
اليوم هو منعطف حقيقي صحيح لكن ما زالت
العمليه يعني للتخلص من هذا النظام البائس
ولاعاده قطار الثوره والديمقراطيه على على
همم يعني على اساسها صحيحه هذا مسؤوليت كل
الاطراف وانا ادعوا كل الاطراف السياسيه
الان الى التحلي باقصى قدر ممكن من ال-
يعني من المسؤوليه حتى نتخلص من هذا من
هذه الدوره المضاده حتى نعيد بالثوره
لبناء المشروع الثوره الدوله الديمقراطيه
شعب المنارع من المواطنين وليس شعب من
الرعايه دوله قانون ومؤسسات في خدمه هذا
الشعب الاستقرار الاصدقاء الان
المسؤوليتنا هي يعني مواكبه هذه الثوره
موصلتها يعني هذه الثوره لم تنتهي هم
كانوا يح بان هذه الثوره انتهت والان
شعبنا اظهر للشعب التونسي وللشعوب العربي
كلها انه لا الثوره هذه متجدده وباقيه وان
شاء الله يعني ستاتي اكلها طالها زمانه او
قصره يعني كانت دائما حينما يتم مقارنه
تونس بدول المشرق العربي ودول الربيع
العربي الاخرى ان تونس مختلفه تونس فيها
نقبه ناضجه نخبه واعيه وفيها الشعب متعلم
لماذا لم يكن هذه لم تكن هذه النخبه
الناضجه الواعيه والشعب المتعلم حصنا من
ان تسير تونس في مسار ثوره الربيع العربي
الاخرى التي اتجهت نحو الاستبدال
السيد الكريم هي بلد عربي تكون البلدان
العربيه فيها نفس نفس الصراعات نفس
التنافسات يعني وقعت عليها مؤامره كبرى
مره اخرى
الثوره العربيه الربيع العربي
[موسيقى]
الفيديو الاقليمي والدولي الذي تعرفه جيدا
حيث القضيه لا تحمل فقط على ذلك السياسيه
واعتبر السياسيه نحن شعب صغير تامرت علينا
قوه جبار الفاسد بالاعلام الفاسد الذي
ثوره وتصورت انك القضيه همم انتهت وان مهد
الثوره العربيه انتهاء كذا كذا فهذا الشعب
اظهر له من جديد هذا غير صحيح
وانهزمنا يعني دائما اقول يعني نحن خسرنا
المعارك لكن سنربح الحرب نحن يعني الشعب
التونسي والشعوب العربيه خسرنا معركه ال
10 سنوات الاخيره عندما امرت كل القوات
الثوره الاجهاضافه في في ليبيا اجهاض في
مصر واجهاضها في تونس لكن كل هذه الشعوب
ستستعيد ثقتها في نفسها وستعيد حركيتها
وستفرغ تحررها شاءت او همم لم تشاء هذه
القوه الاقليميه والدوليه التي تريد الى
العراق ان يبقى دائما تحت الاستبداد
ستفيد المستقبل ستستعيد لكن لماذا لم
تستعد حتى الان
لم تستعد لحد الان بانه هناك ظروف موضوعيه
حقيقيه لكن بين قوس مره اخرى اريد ان اركز
على قراءه الكاس نصف الكاس الملان لان انا
سمعت التقرير يركز فقط على نصف كاساره نصف
كاس الان هو انه اليوم فعلا انه كانت هناك
اربع طبرات لكن هذه الارض مهارات متفقه
على ثلاثه اشياء متفقه على انه هذا
الانقلاب بما معناها العوده الى الدستور
الثوره متفقه ايضا على انه ما نريده
مستقبل هو نظام عسكري ولا نظام حكم فردي
ومتفق على انه يجب العوده الى الانتخابات
الحره لسياده الشعب يعني كل هذه الاطراف
متفقه ماذا تريدون اكثر يعني هذه قصه انه
المعارضه كلها يجب ان تكون الصفا واحده
وراء شخص واحد هذا غير موجود في كل
البلدان العالم هذا قبل كنت اعطيته تصريح
قلت انا كلمه مانديلا اعرف ان مانديلا وما
ادراك لم يستطيع ان يحرر افارقه ضد النظام
كان هناك معركه ما بينه وما بين بوت ميسي
الى اخر لحظه وصارت فيها دماء يعني تقاتل
الافارقه رغم انه مانديلا والعظيم مانديلا
لم يستطع ان يوحد فلماذا تريدون من هذه
الاطراف كلها ان تتحد كلها لا المهم هو ان
تتفق على نهايه الدكتاتوريه وهذا متفقين
عليه على التمسك بدستور للثوره وهذا كل
الاطراف متفقه عليه على الذهاب الانتخابات
حره وانا ذاكري يتنافس المتنافسون اما هذا
نجيب الحكم شر تقول لي انا لا استطيع ان
نؤمن الا اذا كان هناك زعيم او احد انت
هكذا قصه الزعيم الاوحد لا في الحكم ولا
في المعارضه انتهيت هذه القسم الحزب الذي
واحد كل الاطراف الانفاق استراتيجي على
نهايه الاستبداد وعلى الذهاب الى الشعب
الى الانتخابات الحره
هذا هو المطلوب هو نهايه السداد كما تقول
المعارضه كما تفضلت لكن السبيل الى ذلك هل
السبيل الى ذلك فقط باستمرار التظاهر في
الشارع همم
تدخل من القوه التي تدعم او تخلي من القوه
التي تدعم الرئيس قيس سعيد يعني هنالك في
هذا البرنامج همم في بدايه البرنامج تتحدث
احد الضيوف واتهم
مش شخصيا بانكم تدعونا الجيش
للاطاحه بالقيس سعيد
انا اولا انا اعول على الشعب الشعب
المواطنين انا ادعو منذ البدايه الشعب
المواطنين انا انه يمارس يعني بكل قوه ال-
ال- المقاومه المدنيه السلميه كما فعل
الشعب السيرلانكي شعب سريلانكي هو الذي
طرد الديكتاتور
وسبح في يعني في المسبح بتاع القصر انا
ادعوا شعب تونسي مره اخرى الى انه فعلا
ينظم نفسه بكيفيه انه يستطيع بالمقاومه
المدنيه السلميه ان يتخلص من هذا
الديكتاتور يعني مجبره على الفراغ او ان
يضعه في السجن لكن ايضا انا طلبت افعل من
من الجيش ومن الامن ومن القضاه ومن
الاعلاميين من كل تونسيين يتحمله
مسؤوليتهم في ايقاف هذه المهزله لانه تونس
مره اخرى كانت مفخره للعرب اصبحت اليوم
مسخره فعلا اصبحت مسخره يعني لو كان حتى
عندنا الديكتاتور مثل السيسي يعني مسخره
يحكمها هذا الرجل طلبت انه الجيش وكل اللي
هو ان تتحمل مسؤوليه في ازاحه هذا الشخص
لانه لم يعد له اي شرعيه انا انا همم مره
انا اتخذت هذا الرجل ولم يهاجمه مره واحده
لكن لما انقلب على الدستور اعتبرته رئيس
سيرعي وهو ليس مؤهل لان يعطي اوامر لا
للجيش ولا للامن ولا القضاء القضاه والجيش
والامن وكلهم في حل من اطاعه رجل انقلب
على الدستور وضع يده على القران على
المصحف الشريف وحدث بان يحمي الدستور ونقض
وحده واصبح رئيس غير شرعي اضافه لهذا يذكر
بانه الشعب رفض له في الاستشاره 50% رفضوا
المشاركه في الاستشاره 75% رفضوا يعني همم
التصويت على الدستور 90% رفضوا الانتخابات
اي رسائل اكثر من هذا الجيش
غير شرعي وبالتالي يجب ان يرحل وكل يوم
يبقى في هذا الرجل في السلطه الا وتزداد
الحاله تعفنه وفقر يزداد والمصائص تزداد
ما عندناش حل اخر غير نهايه هذا الانقلاب
حتى تعود تونسي الحاله الطبيعيه وحتى يعود
الاقتصادي الى حالته الطبيعيه
طيب دكتور المصري يعني تقول الجيش يتدخل
اليس هذا انقلاب يعني اذا تدخل الجيش في
اي بلد هذا انقلاب ليس نستبد الانقلاب
هو الذي وقع في في تونس عندما حدث هذا
الرجل وعندما كذب على الشعب الذي انتخبه
منه انا حاله بان يحمل دستور فانقلب عليه
اذا هذا الرجل اصبح غير شرعي وبالتالي على
كل القوه التونسيه الشعب المواطنين الذي
ادعوه الى التمسك بالمقاومه المدني
السلميه وايضا انا اقول لك انا كنت قاعد
على القوات المسلحه وكنت انتظر من الجيش
ان يدعم الثوره والجيش دعم الثوره لان كنت
اريد رئيس شرعي تمسك بالشرعيه عندما خسرت
الانتخابات ذهبت في حال سبيله الى اخره
هذا رجل خرج على الشرعيه
اذا الجيش وكل المؤسسات وشعب المواطنين
هذا الرجل وان يعطى يكون درس لي كل انسان
يريد مره اخرى ان يدخل الديمقراطيه وان
يضرب الديمقراطيه من الداخليه لها اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من باريس الدكتور المنصف مخيف
الرئيس التونسي الاسبق شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا